I have to ask you how it feels you know
to be an actor for a couple of days it
was weird
I've never done it before there's my
fake time this morning I had to come in
there and get makeup that stuff is this
a new experience for me mr. learning
experience there's a lot easier to come
to work every morning Hale with Brandes
and how is he doing how's he doing he's
doing great
well first time after I paid
because there was we were watching you
work
Kobe and as we saw everybody goes up on
a line you know flubs up and and you
were flooded up I mean it's not you're
used to being in front of crowds is it
kind of different that one that the
director is like saying do this do that
Randy the show has made a point of not
only doing comedy but in a sense doing
wrapping the comedy around issues what's
the issue for this episode that I think
the issue is if you can do something
once you can do it again and we can do
it much better than the first time
he takes the SATs and people think I
took it for him it's not true so and he
does it again he passes it even with the
highest score so I think if you can do
something once you can always do it
again and Kobe I don't know did did you
is this an experience it really happened
to you I mean did you take the SATs and
do all that stuff or always said you
know well this is it saying I did do
real well and I didn't ask anybody
taking the now we've heard reports that
you guys are dating or you're we went to
the prom together did you hear that you
always have you been out since then yeah
hanging out going to the places oh how
do you describe the relationship item
very funny what is it is it like for you
to I mean obviously you've you have come
to this point the last couple of years
people have known both of you for four
different things but you've been in the
public eye and this is this is kind of
new people asking you questions about
being a couple or having pictures
snapped how is that for you yeah people
forget you know they mean you are you
know 18 and how are you paying their
fees eighty nine seventeen alright
seventeen now let's get let's get the
hard-hitting questions all right now
when you go out who does the driving he
has a limo up there like I have to
impress these girls limo and drinks in
the limo cold sprite whatever you want
he has it all prepared now when it comes
to the end of the evening and the waiter
brings that brings the you know the
receipts you know who treats I mean
you're both thanks at hiring all her
good looks I'm getting them for free I
say no more now the the Laker season is
fast approaching Brandi we're gonna see
you down there at the other forum yeah
I'll be a cheerleader and Co how is the
transition to this Coast to this
particular town I mean and all of this
camera crews everywhere you turn no I
know I'm not used to this but walking
out the other cameras I'm just gonna be
myself and I just have a good time
the right now we are seeing NBA stars
who are crossing over the two most
obvious are Shaquille and and and
Michael Jordan who are both behind big
movies is that something that you could
see you I mean this is you of course
your first pass at it but is it
something that you might want to follow
in their footsteps in that like I said
before what you show is ly easy today
hanging out with a great cast you know I
get to play the same with Randy's tutor
it was like some movie last news on the
drama world something like night
[Music]